NATION.
IF YOU ARE THE IN MILITARY YOU
GET FREE ACCESS FOR A YEAR.
THE DEFENSE CONTRACT FOR
LOCKHEED MARTIN ORDERED THEM TO
A SEMINAR TO UNLEARN THEIR WHITE
MALE PRIVILEGE.
CHRIS IS A SENIOR FELLOW AND
BROKE THIS STORY.
TELL US WHAT THIS TRAINING
SESSION WAS LIKE.
WHAT WENT ON AT THIS THING?
>> WELL, THIS IS A LONG TRAINING
PROGRAM.
8,000 LOCKHEED MARTIN EMPLOYEES
HAVE BEEN THROUGH RACE
REEDUCATION PROGRAMS.
THEY SAID BEING A WHITE MALE WAS
LIKE BEING IN THE KKK AND THEY
SAID WHITE MEN CAN'T JUMP.
ALL OF THESE SLURS ABOUT THEIR
OWN ORIGINS.
THEY TAKE THEM THROUGH A SERIES
OF EXERCISES.
THEY HAVE TO REVIEW 156 WHITE
MALE PRIVILEGE STATEMENTS.
THE QUESTION IS THIS:
IF A 3 STAR GENERAL IN THE U.S.
MILITARY CAN'T STAND UP TO
CRACKPOT DIVERSITY TRAINERS, HOW
DO WE STAND UP TO CHINA?
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS COMPANY WOULD NOT EXIST
WITHOUT FEDERAL CONTRACT.
GET BILLION DOLLARS FROM
CONGRESS.
WILL ANYONE IN CONGRESS PUT A
STOP TO THIS?
>> YES, I HOPE SO.
LOCKHEED MARTIN HAS TENS OF
BILLION DOLLARS COME FROM
TAXPAYERS.
HOW MANY PROGRAMS DENIGRATE
WHITE MALES HAS LOCKHEED MARTIN
DONE?
I CALL ON THE U.S. SENATE AND
THE U.S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO LAUNCH AN
INQUIRY TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS.
TAXPAYER SHOULD NOT SUBSIDIZE
WOKE RACISM AT AMERICA'S LARGEST
CORPORATION.
>> Tucker: WAS THERE ANY
RESPONSE FROM LOCKHEED MARTIN?
>> YES, THEY RESPONDED TODAY
WITH A STATEMENT THAT COULD ONLY
BE DESCRIBED AS CORPORATE
GIBBERISH.
I THINK THEY HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
AND THEY ARE SCRAMBLING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESPOND.
THE DOCUMENTS ON MY TWITTER
HANDLE AND MY WEBSITE ARE
DAMNING.
NO BONUS ABOUT IT, THIS IS A
NEO- RACIST PROGRAM FORCED
EMPLOYEES.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE YOU THE ONLY
JOURNALIST DOING THIS STORY?
>> PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK
OUT ON THESE ISSUES.
IT WILL TAKE MORE PEOPLE TO HAVE
THE COURAGE TO STAND UP AND
SPEAK OUT AND A RACISM IS WRONG
NO MATTER WHERE IT COMES FROM
AND WHO IT IS DIRECTED TOWARDS.
THAT SHOULD BE SIMPLE BUT IT'S
SCARY FOR TOO MANY PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THE ADULT MEN WHO PUT
UP WITH THIS DESERVE IT.
BUT I STILL THINK